Hi,
Dr. Peterson,
I would just like to ask you to please talk about what you called a psychic
death,
also known as an ego death.
Okay,
sorry,
say that again.
Would you please talk about what young referred to as a psychic death also
called an ego death.
That's what happens when someone who loves you betrays you.
Right?
So imagine that
the world is complicated beyond comprehension,
right?
When you only see a very little bit of it and the way you structure your
understanding is you make assumptions about things and they're simplifying
assumption.
So if you trust someone,
you reduce their complexity massively,
right?
Because like,
let's say we were married and there's a whole bunch of ways that you're going to
act that are going to be simpler.
Okay.
So then I can tolerate being around you in some sense because you're not
everything at once.
Now those simplifying structures are hierarchically assembled and some of them
are far more important than others.
Trust is one of them,
especially trust in loved ones,
family members,
which is why I'd be trailed by a family member is really catastrophic cause it
it an it destabilizes your past,
right?
All the memories you have at de stabilizes your present.
It destabilizes your future.
It shakes your faith in human beings,
including yourself and everything collapses.
And that's an ego death.
And so now underneath the ego as far as young was concerned,
was another structure that he called the self.
And the self is the thing that remains constant across ego deaths,
but it's,
it's deeper and less personal.
It's archetipal and it's the thing that the eagle collapses into when it
collapses and then it rebuilds the ego,
something like that across time.
But that's what an ego death is.
Now there's variants of that because you can have a voluntary or involuntary ego
death and a voluntary ego death is when you learn a bunch and you're willing to
let go.
So that would be your own immolation.
It's like your lighting,
your,
you're a Phoenix and your lighting yourself on fire.
That's a much better idea.
Even though it can still be really harsh,
the involuntary ego desks,
they're really hard on people.
People will do almost anything to stop that from happening,
which is partly why they fight to maintain their group fostered axiomatic
simplifications.
It's not surprising because it's very,
you lose your,
like that ego death is a journey into the underworld or it's a collapse into
chaos.
And that's not so bad if you do it purposefully.
But in the Pinocchio Story,
for example,
that's exemplified by Pinocchio going down to the depths to rescue his father
from the whale.
Now he does that voluntarily,
but it damn near killed him,
right?
I mean,
first of all,
you hardly gets out of the whale.
Second,
he actually drowns and dies,
but he comes back to life.
So even if you do it voluntarily,
it's still,
it's just better than doing it in voluntarily,
which is the other alternative.
So that's what it is.
You Bet.